senna point fr
bonsoir à tous philippe marini le
président ump de la commission des
finances est l'invité de preuves par 3
bonsoir australie merci d'être avec nous
et je vous interrogerait d'abord comme
président d'honneur du groupe d'amitié
france syrie bien sûr à l'heure du
projet de résolution qui pourrait éviter
les frappes aériennes
nous parlerons ensuite du budget pause
fiscale ou pas comme le dit le
gouvernement
et vous répondrai aux questions de
deborah claude de l' agence
france-presse
notre partenaire avec dailymotion enfin
perrine tarneaud ne rejoindra pour la
troisième partie de l'émission et pour
parler notamment de l'ump dans le
candidat pour 2017 sera à coup sûr vous
en est persuadé nicolas sarkozy et vous
le dit alors que vous étiez dans son
bureau il y a encore quelques heures
vous pouvez nous en dire beaucoup plus
tout à l'heure philippe marini d'abord
l'ouverture sur les armes chimiques
l'ouverture puis le départ la russie
confort tels votre conviction que bachar
el-assad est un bon politique on peut
être odieux et avoir des qualités de
manoeuvre c'est pas du tout
contradictoire
la formule a choqué oui mais il fallait
lire ce qu'ils suivaient pas séparés
trois mots dans un texte
maintenant je ne dirais pas que dans
cette affaire pardonnez-moi le raccourci
président hollande est était un bon
politique il doit essayer de trouver une
solution pour rétropédaler il aa pris
apparemment de façon inattendue que le
président obama avait besoin du vote de
ces assemblées il n'est pas semblable
des hésitations du président américain
reconnaissait le certes mais quand on
est une puissance militaire qui ne peut
pas intervenir seul mais qui néanmoins
est une puissance indépendante se lier
ce livre est un tel point à des
décisions étrangères à des décisions
américaines cela m'a choqué et je
et réagit dès le départ de cette
question des armes chimiques en disant
que la position de la france était
beaucoup trop suiviste à l'égard des
états unis
je persiste et je signe et je pense que
depuis des mois et des mois nous aurions
dû nous rapprocher de la diplomatie
russe car ce que nous n'avons pas fait
et n'avons pas voulu faire et là nous
aurions pu apporter notre valeur ajoutée
faire quelque chose alors qu'aujourd'hui
nous sommes prêts la peau diplomatie
russe et l'état totalement alignée sur
la position syrienne gta taux d'intérêt
sans lui compliquer c'est pas blanc et
noirs c'était un peu plus compliqué
si l'on avait voulu on aurait pu
apporter notre valeur ajoutée est de la
même manière que si l'on avait été
sensible aux signes adressés par le
nouveau président élu en iran
je pense qu'on aurait pu trouver aussi
de ce côté-là des marges pour une
originalité française
la france dit aujourd'hui et notamment
par la voix de laurent fabius le
ministre des affaires étrangères que ce
mouvement sur les armes chimiques est dû
aux pressions occidentales et notamment
de la france
il peut le dire il faut bien que les
héros des affaires étrangères disent
quelque chose ce n'est pas la réalité
je la remets menace le fera mais nous
avons pesé dans cette évolution tient
plus efficace depuis des mois et des
mois ci ne nous étions pas lié à ce
point avec l'opposition syrienne
nous aurions dû rester au-dessus de la
mêlée éviter d'être engagés dans cette
guerre civile alors vous je vais vous
poser la question sur bachar el-assad 1
2 par vos relations anciennes avec lui
un philippe taris neigeait encore une
question sur françois hollande il s'est
dit très choqué par l'interview très
récente de bachar el-assad dans le
figaro dans laquelle c'est vrai il
promettait de liquider ses opposants ça
c'est une formule qui a alerté le chef
de l'état est ce qu'elle vous heurte
également mais moi je l'étais aussi mais
par une autre partie de l'interview
lorsqu ils caricaturent l'évolution de
la diplomatie française en 2008 en
l'attribuant à l' influence des etats
unis alors que je suis bien placé pour
savoir que c'est totalement faux donc
c'est quelqu'un qui n'hésite pas à dire
tout à fait le contraire de la vérité
alors vous avez également choqué en
affirmant que le dictateur est doté d'un
esprit moderne qu'est ce que vous voulez
dire par là ils pratiquent
l'informatique il a été éduqué à
l'occidentale enfin il ne vit pas sous
un turban il est il et il est oui il met
les maîtres il massacre son peuple mais
il dirige un régime qui depuis l'origine
est un régime dictatorial policier est
particulièrement antipathique et en
effet il est le patron effectifs de ce
régime d'accord mais là on est passé à
une autre étape avec les illusions de
sang oui bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr on
est alors on y va on a découvert les
syriens des deux parties en sont
collectivement responsables ayez la
gentillesse de lire le très beau texte
mais vraiment le très beau texte y
compris sur le plan littéraire voire
poétique du journaliste italien qui
vient d'être libéré je les lui elle est
une figure elle au nord de rigueur dans
le monde
c'est un récit qui honore votre métiers
et
vous y lirez quand il dit j'ai rencontré
lé empire du mal en quelques étapes des
islamistes
il parle de la syrie d'aujourd'hui de ce
pays en guerre civile où des bandes se
répand sur le territoire et où il ya un
amalgame entre la politique et les
intérêts l'argent et l'islam et s'il y a
quelque chose à sauvegarder en syrie
quel que soit le caractère négatif voire
détestable jusqu'à un certain point du
régime baassiste c'est l'état
les syriens ont besoin d'être protégés
par un état ils ont besoin d'une justice
ils ont besoin d'une police ils ont
besoin d'une administration ils ont
besoin d'un système qu'ils ont besoin
david luiz ce qui s'est passé en irak
par exemple certes car en irak des
milliers de milliards de dollars ont été
dépensés et où on est le pays
on y meurt encore tous les jours tous
les mois ce sont des milliers de
personnes le pays est divisé et le
gouvernement de bagdad et sous
l'influencé de l'iran ce qui n'était pas
me semble-t-il exactement le but
poursuivi à l'origine est ce que le
démantèlement proposé de l'arsenal
chimiques syrien et je crois qu'il ya
plus de deux mille bombes pourraient
être un piège
je ne suis pas un technicien mais je
pense que l'état syrien est amené à cela
il faut naturellement saisir cette
opportunité et neutralisaient cet
arsenal sous contrôle international
il y à des personnes beaucoup plus
compétentes que moi sur le plan
militaire qui sont capables là en termes
diplomatiques par exemple ça se joue
dans les heures qui viennent nous elle
est favorable à une résolution
contraignante tout pour la syrie tout
plutôt que la guerre tout plutôt que des
frappes qui ajouterait de la violence à
la violence des victimes civiles aux
victimes civiles et qui se traduirait
probablement par des métastases
supplémentaires dans d'autres pays du
proche orient
mais bien sûr ne pas faire preuve de
naïveté et mettre en oeuvre un
dispositif international qui soit
applicable contrôlable transparente vous
avez moquer il ya un instant françois
hollande vous l'avait critiquée pour son
alignement sur les etats-unis
aujourd'hui même françois hollande et
barack obama se sont longuement parlé au
téléphone il
welt agir ensemble à l'onu c'est une
bonne chose pour le coup mais sans aucun
doute vous savez en début d'année j'ai
soutenu et complimenter françois
hollande pour ce que nous avons fait et
d'ailleurs scène au mali donc je ne suis
pas systématiquement un compte en odeur
de l'action internationale
mais l'amour mali la france était tout
seul au départ et on a bien fait d'y
aller il y aller dans ces conditions là
est-ce que bachar el-assad donc l'esprit
moderne un bon politique et marini est
totalement discrédité pour la suite pour
l'avenir selon vous cent mille morts il
y a une échéance présidentielle
parait-il en 2014
est ce que des élections sont possibles
dans les conditions qui prévalent en
syrie ça me paraît un peu un peu
difficile à considérer je crois qu'il
faut respecter l'indépendance de chaque
état vous savez je n'ai jamais dit que
la série seulement avoir un avenir mais
je n'ai la syrie a besoin d'un état
je n'ai personnellement jamais été en
faveur du devoir d'ingérence pardonnez
moi c'est ma petite différence
de ce point de vue là je ne suis ni
comme bernard kouchner ni comme alain
juppé d'alors alain juppé justement qui
dit qu'on ne rien faire serait se rendre
complice de crime contre une contre
l'humanité vous n'approuvez pas cette
phrase je pense que l'option punir le
méchant qui nous a été vendu pendant des
jours et des jours n'est pas une option
pour une intervention militaire
on intervient militairement pour
défendre des intérêts des intérêts
stratégiques en particulier et non pas
pour punir vous savez à quoi ça me
faisait penser le terme de punir leurs
dettes au vieil empereur françois joseph
qui voulait punir la serbie au début du
mois d'août 1914 pour le meurtre de son
héritier maintenant on peut s'interroger
aurait mieux fait qu'il ne le fasse pas
car son empire a disparu alors on peut
s'interroger
multiplié les références historiques par
exemple john kerry secrétaire d'état
américain a dénoncé un munich lui il a
fait référence à la lâcheté face à
hitler
comment est ce que vous avez reçu cette
évocation de munich qui avait d'ailleurs
utilisé harlem désir avant lui je pense
que c'est une référence un peu un peu
forcé même si bachar el-assad a des
côtés plus qu'antipathique voire odieux
et la syrie blond est un pays de 21
millions d'habitants
ce n'est pas l'allemagne de 1933 ou de
1939 c'est quasiment au même point
bachar al assad vous ne pourriez plus
vit serré la main demain si j'ai été
missionné pour défendre les intérêts de
la france auprès de lui dans je le ferai
mais je pense qu'il y à bien des gens
odieux sur la planète voire indéfendable
et qui ont réalisé de nombreuses
injustices et qui sont nos
interlocuteurs probablement tous les
jours probablement tous les jours bon
celui-là il se trouve qu'aujourd'hui et
pour des raisons évidentes il est sous
les projecteurs mais on est sous les
projecteurs un jour et puis choses
évoluent qui aux jeunes venant à cent
mille morts derrière soi qui aujourd'hui
nous reparle des violences en egypte
c'est une question qui semble avoir
disparu de l'horizon des rédactions
vous avez vous été choqué en tenant ce
genre de propos monsieur marriner on dit
souvent qu'avec le diable
il ne faut déjeuner qu'avec une longue
cuillère mais si l'on a à défendre
soyons bien clairs si l'on a à défendre
des intérêts des intérêts collectifs
dont on est porteur
si l'on pense pouvoir faire le bien
grâce à un contact et en allant dans le
sens d'un apaisement dans le sens de la
paix quel que soit l'interlocuteur il
faut le faire la syrie elle est ce
qu'elle est le jour où un règlement
politique sera en vue il ne le sera
qu'avec les vrais acteurs réellement sur
le terrain
on ne peut pas fabriquer avec des
émigrés une apparence d'état on doit
parler avec ceux qui sont sur le terrain
et bachar el-assad quels que soient les
reproches presque infinie que l'on peut
lui il est là il est là encore pour
longtemps les écouter il est là il
existe pour l'entente le devenir je n'en
sais strictement rien le devenir de la
syrie dépend pour une part de lui c'est
le réalisme qui compte aujourd'hui en
tous les cas un mot sur barack obama et
ses volte-face
comment est-ce que vous jugez la
présidence américaine je suis allé au
mois de mai aux états unis vont sur des
problématiques économiques et
financières j'ai constaté que la
situation politique elle étaient bloqués
n'est ce pas ceci s'est traduit par ce
qu'on a appelé la falaise budgétaire
c'est-à-dire un possibilité d'une
entente entre l'exécutif et la chance
sur la présidence obama le feu la
présidence obama est nécessairement mal
parce que quelqu'un qui aurait besoin
pour obtenir un vote parlementaire de
ses ennemis politiques donc des
républicains les plus opposés à ce qu'il
représente et qui n'obtiendrait pas le
soutien de ses amis de ceux qui ont été
comme lui en faveur du retrait d'irak et
d'afghanistan
c'est quand même terminé assez mal allez
on va parler du budget maintenant si
vous voulez bien et des efforts du
gouvernement pour réduire le déficit
françois hollande réclame une pause
fiscale promet ce fantasme ou réalité
avant d'en parler avec deborah claude de
l' agence france presse d'explications
et l'équation budgétaire
toujours aussi délicate avec faustine
saint geniès
françois hollande l'a annoncé le temps
est venu de faire une pause fiscale ce
sera pour le budget 2014
une proposition précise et par le
ministre du budget la semaine dernière
contre un objectif c'est d'aller vers la
stabilisation de la pression fiscale
avec un an d'avancé
aussi longtemps que nous parviendrons à
faire davantage d'économies et je
souhaite que ce soit la doctrine que ce
soit le moyen que soit l'instrument nous
n'aurons pas faire d'impôt chaque
économie supplémentaire ce sont des
impôts en moins pour les français et moi
je vais être le ministre des économies
pas le ministre des impôts
au programme pour les entreprises une
baisse de l'impôt sur les sociétés et
une réforme en vue pour simplifier la
fiscalité la pause fiscale
une bonne nouvelle pour tous les
contribuables pas si sûr les ménages
profiteront d'un retour à un barème
d'imposition indexées sur l'inflation
mais avec en contrepartie la perte de
nombreux avantages pour les familles
comme la baisse du quotient familial une
hausse de la tva de 19,6 à 20 % pour le
taux supérieur et une augmentation des
cotisations retraite de 0 15% pour tous
les salariés au total
l'état espère ainsi récupérer 6
milliards d'euros la pause fiscale oui
mais pas vraiment pour les ménages une
mesure qui risque de peser sur la
consommation et donc sur les entreprises
pour cet économiste
c'est absurde au cosec si vous augmentez
les impôts de déménager notamment des
classes moyennes qui sont quand même le
support de la consommation vous ne jouez
pas sur les entreprises c'est pas une
pause qu'il nous faut c'est une
réduction des de ces prélèvements
et pour cause le taux de prélèvements
obligatoires pour l'année 2013 s'élève
déjà à 46,3 pour cent du pib un record
depuis la création des statistiques
il devrait encore augmenter en 2014
voilà deborah claude de l' agence france
presse nous a rejoint bonsoir deborah
alors vos questions à philippe marini
président de la commission des finances
pas une question bien sûr sûr sûr les
impôts qu'attendent les français puis
sur l'état de nos comptes publics
c'est la période du budget va bientôt
être présentées vous êtes un des
français qui est le mieux informé sur le
prénom ce public alors dans quel état
sont les finances publiques de la france
est-ce qu'il faut croire à cette pause
fiscale ou par le président de la
république il faut bien comprendre ce
dont il peut s'agir pause fiscale
si l'on l'interprète pause fiscale comme
absence d'augmentations d'impôts
c'est faux c'est faux car en 2014 il
faudra au moins compenser 4 milliards
d'euros de mesures provisoires de 2013
les remplacer par autre chose il faudra
financer pour 4 milliards d'euros le
crédit d'impôt compétitivité emploi
et puisque l'on a ce qui est sans doute
une bonne décision acceptée d'indexer à
nouveau le barème de l'impôt sur le
revenu c'est un manque à gagner de 1,7
milliard d'euros sur louis moi je pense
qu'il n'aurait pas fallu le bloquer les
années précédentes et alors que vous
avez fait le total des moins cause du
mont total ment total c'est une dizaine
de milliards de recettes qu'il faudra
trouver par ailleurs sous forme d'
accroissement de la pression fiscale
c'est l'arithmétique et le dit il s'y
ajoute les prévisions que l'on peut
faire en matière de croissance et il
faudra naturellement être vigilant à ce
sujet et vigilant sur les recettes
fiscales de l'année 2014
par ailleurs il a été dit semble-t-il
que les entreprises seraient indemme en
des promesses leur ont été faites par
exemple pour compenser les hausses de
cotisations dans le cadre de la réforme
des retraites
je ne sais pas comment on va compenser
mais je suppose que la contrepartie se
trouvera
sur les ménages parce qu'il n'ya pas
trente-six contrepartie possible
il y à la baisse de la dépense publique
il y à la fiscalité sur les ménages
est ce qui d'ailleurs une reprise est ce
que la croissance va repartir nous
sommes dans une situation un peu
meilleure mais relativisons nous étions
dans une situation de stagnation - nous
sommes dans une situation de stagnation
plus moins de 1 % de croissance annuelle
nous avons vu sortir le chiffre de la
production manufacturière et qui n'est
pas bon le chiffre de la balance
extérieure n'est pas bon non plus la
france perd des points de compétitivité
et la france ne crée pas d'emplois et
vous savez que pour créer des emplois il
faut que le taux de croissance repasse
au-dessus du seuil des 1,5 pour cent
minimum minimorum donc ne nous
réjouissons pas trop vite il faut être
prudent
il faut être prudent je voudrais aussi
dire que nos amis britanniques viennent
de sortir des statistiques de croissance
qui sont sensiblement meilleurs que
prévu or leur politique a été d'être
incitatif vis-à-vis des entreprises de
faire bénéficier les entreprises de
certaines baisses d'impôts et par
ailleurs de taille est assez
vigoureusement dans les dépenses
publiques avant les dépenses que
justement ce que vous ne mentionnez pas
philippe marini je les ai mentionné
comme facteur d'ajustement est à cet
égard et on voudrait que l'on nous dise
la vérité et du budget bernard cazeneuve
dit que jamais un effort aussi important
n'aurait été réalisés demeura en tout
cas je vois dans les chiffres et dans la
programmation des finances publiques
l'an prochain il nous faudrait une
inflexion négative des dépenses
publiques état sécurité sociale
collectivités locales de l'ordre de 14
milliards d'euros 14 milliards d'euros
d'économies de dépenses qui pour moi ne
sont pas à ce jour documenté de manière
précise sur un autre sujet un peu
sensible
sensible les niches fiscales touche
apparemment aux niches scolaire
différentes autres pistes sont à l'étude
vous préconisez quoi c'est un débat qui
a toujours secoué la droite ou à gauche
parce qu'on ne sait pas où touché dans
chaque niche il ya un chien on y est
toujours alors où est ce qu'il faut ce
ne pas se faire mordre
voilà j'ai un peu la question bercy
c'est à dire qu'il faut faire maigrir le
chien tous les chiens de toutes les
niches en d'autres termes est assis il
mordra mois à la lente mais bon mais
peut-être mais je veux dire par là que
la méthode utilisée
d'ailleurs elle l'était par le précédent
gouvernement aussi et qui consiste à
viser individuellement tel ou tel régime
telle ou telle niche en les prenant à
tit séquentielle les unes après les
autres n'est pas une bonne méthode
parce que ça prend beaucoup de temps ça
et rentes les milieux concernés se
descendent sur le plan de l'opinion
publique c'est négatif avis la meilleure
approche c'est de tout réduire
proportionnellement et en quelques
années faire disparaître la plus grande
partie de ces niches ce qui est un enjeu
de dizaines de milliards d'euros et
permettrait d'abaisser un peu les taux
nominaux de l'impôt sur les sociétés
comme ceux de problèmes comme ceux de la
rue non sur le revenu
non c'est ma vision constante rires vous
savez si j'ai subi c'est une annonce du
chef de l'état apparemment qui veut
baisser le taux de l'impôt sur les
sociétés oui mais il faudra qu'ils
compensent par ce qu'il y a le solde est
même si les trois pour cent ne sont plus
que pour 2015
encore faux 2% en 2015 le déficit de sa
vie
il faudra bien y arriver si l'on ne veut
pas être étrillé par les marchés
financiers
mais vauzelle nous avons pris des
engagements
nous ne tenons pas nous sommes dès
maintenant en dehors des clous du pacte
de stabilité qui a été approuvé par
l'assemblée nationale au printemps
nous sommes tout à fait à l'extérieur de
cela d'ailleurs pierre moscovici l'a
reconnu il l'a reconnu en nous disant
que à la fin de l'année 2013
nous serions moins bien que les 3 7%
prévus
donc on partira en début d'année 2014
sur une base qui sera détériorer les
efforts seront encore plus grand à faire
or vous l'évoquez je crois les marchés
financiers sont plutôt orientés à
nouveau à la hausse des taux d'intérêt
ça veut dire qu'on va payer beaucoup
plus cher un autre net pour l'année 2013
nous sommes encore bon parce que par
rapport aux prévisions qui avaient été
faites
je pense que nous serons à l'équilibré
voir avec un bonus encore significatif
mais quid de l'année 2014
et qu'est ce qui nous dit qu'il n'y aura
pas au niveau de la zone rouge où dans
le monde des causes de fragilité
financière et qui conduiront les marchés
à s'emballer à nouveau nous sommes
vulnérables
tant que nous ne respectons pas le
retour aux 3% et c'est pas pour une
fantaisie européenne qu'il faut le faire
ou même simplement pour respecter notre
parole c'est parce que tant que l'on n'a
pas atteint ce seuil la dette en capital
continue à augmenter l'engrais
pessimiste je suis réaliste et je pense
que le gouvernement à trouver parce
qu'il est bon communicateur ce
gouvernement je le reconnais 1
il a trouvé une bonne expression avec
pause fiscale
et lorsqu'on va se rendre compte que
comme bien d'autres choses qui ont été
dites
ce n'est pas la vérité vécue par nos
concitoyens
cette habileté se retournera contre lui
sur la taxe à 75% alors je ne sais pas
s'il a été très habile communicateur le
gouvernement
il doit s'y reprendre une seconde fois
on va voir la saison 2 de la famille
durant la campagne présidentielle de
françois hollande
là c'est le candidat qui avait été
habile oui la qualité a surgi donc on va
avoir la deuxième mouture qui va sortir
bientôt il était question ce matin
qu'elles soient exonérés pour les clubs
de football c'est peut-être anecdotique
mais qu'est ce que vous en pensez
encore une niche on supprime une biche
manquerait une autre voie la cccc c'est
extraordinaire c'est notre comportement
fiscal
souvenez vous un jour l'ancien président
de la république avait dit peut-être
aurait-il supprimer l' isf aussitôt j'ai
vu arriver ceux qui conseillent la
défiscalisation l'investissement dans
les pme grâce à l'exonération du sf
ils sont venus ils sont tenus dire
monsieur le sénateur lorsqu'il aura plus
de sf il faut qu'on garde notre avantage
il faut nous le recréer c'est
complètement fou mais quelle différence
faites vous entre les hausses d'impôts
quand étaient infligés aux françaises
sous la droite parce qu'il y en a eu
quand même quelques dizaines de
milliards philippe parini et celle que
l'on doit supporter en plus aujourd'hui
mais je pense que le gouvernement actuel
à ses responsabilités comme le précédent
à mon avis il a détérioré l'équation
il a pris des mesures de coisy revanche
à l'été 2012
il aurait très bien pu éviter cela il a
donné des signaux de laxisme budgétaire
par exemple à l'égard de la fonction
publique et ceci accroît les difficultés
et puis il a en quelque sorte pendant
des mois
nier les réalités avant le tournant de
louis gallois et et l'épisode du cic eux
ils crédit d'impôts est ce que sur la
fraude fiscale un autre sujet qui est
venu ces derniers mois sur le tapis à la
faveur de la sphère cahuzac
est ce que le gouvernement fait assez
est-ce que ça va permettre de faire
rentrer de l'argent dans les caisses de
l'état
qu'est ce que vous pensez des
dispositifs qui ont été
ou qui sont encore en navette
parlementaire puisque tout n'est pas été
encore adopté je les ai approuvé pour
une bonne part j'ai même inspiré un
amendement sur l'abus de droit pour
réduire les possibilités d'optimisation
fiscale internationale
je pense que l'état doit se faire
respecter bien entendu merci deborah
avant d'aborder la suite
un mot encore sur la syrie philippe
marini puisque la russie fait savoir
qu'elle juge inacceptable le projet de
français de résolutions à l'onu
on a énuméré tout à l'heure les
conditions que vous les posez paris donc
à ce projet concernant le démantèlement
de l'arsenal chimiques syrien que pensez
vous de ce position paris montre qu'il
n'est pas au coeur du jeu diplomatique
encore une fois ce que l'on n'a pas fait
pendant des mois et il est très
difficile de le récupérer en quelques
heures
est-ce pas ne voulait nous n'avons pas
eu dans cette affaire
l'attitude la politique diplomatique
nous plaçant au dessus de la mêlée et
nous rendant aptes à discuter à négocier
avec les uns et avec les aînés
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui en nous il fait
ça mais il n'est pas légitime que la
france et les états unis d'ailleurs
ensemble je le disais tout à l'heure
impose des conditions dans cette
résolution
à la suite de l'ouverture russe il
appartient à la communauté
internationale et définir sous l'égide
de l'onu et du conseil de sécurité les
conditions auxquelles les stocks d'armes
chimiques syriens devront être à ce
printemps c'est une responsabilité de la
communauté internationale et return de
public sénat va donc nous rejoindre
maintenant pour aborder plusieurs
questions politiques notamment
eh bien ces petites phrases de françois
fillon qui fait grand bruit je sais pas
chez vous vous avez une doublure dans un
instant en tous les cas
et là surprise il a expliqué que le
parti socialiste pouvait être parfois
plus sectaires que le front national
sophie normands ou ps ou fn françois
fillon persiste et signe
l'ex premier ministre veut en finir avec
la ligne défendue par nicolas sarkozy ni
front républicain ni front national le
fameux lit ni calcul ou improvisation
son invitation à voter pour le moins
sectaires des candidats en cas de duel
ps fn surprend à droite maladresse pour
le président de l'udps et jean louis
borloo bêtise pour le député benoist
apparu
à l'ump il ya aussi ce que le sujet
embarrasse il ya ceux qui à demi-mot
soutiennent françois fillon je pense que
c'est ce que pense à mon avis
80% des français cette nouvelle posture
est d'autant plus surprenante que l'ex
premier ministre est sûre et il ya
encore peu qu'ils appelleraient toujours
à voter contre le fn
pour le parti d'extrême droite cette
inflexion est purement stratégique mot
la tactique à l'état c'est clair la
tactique politicienne c'est à dire que
son coeur est au ps mais il ya sur le
terrain une pression parce que les gens
veulent et que
front national et des élus parce que
nous pesons de plus en plus parce que
nous sommes en passe de devenir la
première force de france dans beaucoup
de régions
alors il est obligé d'adapter un petit
peu sa tactique et son discours le ps
s'est lui aussi saisi du sujet pour le
parti de la majorité l'ex premier
ministre perd la boussole républicaine
élèves une digue supplémentaire et cela
su aussi aller cette montée du front
national en abandonnant les principes
qu'il qualifié lui-même être le socle
républicain et il disait que le front
national n'en faisait pas partie
une banalisation du fn qui ouvre la voie
d'un discours nouveau destinée à
reconquérir une partie de l'électorat de
droite avec nous sur ce thème récurrent
des front national et les rapports avec
l'ump
est-ce que selon vous fait parler la
langue de françois fillon a fourché
dimanche dernier sa déclaration m'a
surpris ça veut dire qu'il est encore
capable de surprendre
françois fillon est qu'il est capable de
prendre des risques
cela paraît peu cohérent avec tout ce
qu'il a dit jusqu'ici sur le même sujet
vous en pensez quoi vous personnellement
je vous connaissez ma position je les
livre est à de nombreuses occasions y
compris ici même donc je renvoie dos à
dos et je ne connais pas d'ailleurs
l'agencé de rating permettant d'évaluer
le degré de sectarisme relative des uns
et des autres est ce que vous pensez
quand une majorité de votre groupe ump
au sénat dont votre président est jean
claude gaudin que françois fillon doit
éclaircir sa position parce qu'elle est
elle va à l'encontre de la position
officielle de l'ump inquiets le ni ni ni
fn ni ps je pense qu'il faut en rester à
notre position oui bien entendu c'est
encore satisfaisant la mini c'est bien
toujours la route l'imposition
c'est notre position il faut l'assumer
comme tel cette question n'est pas
dépasser est ce que les dernières
élections n'ont pas montré que
finalement les électeurs ne tenait pas
compte des consignes de vote
ses lecteurs sont libres de leur vote
vous dites que vous n'avez pas les
agences de notation pourraient juger si
le front national et sectaires ou pas où
tu payes un seul candidat
son programme parle pour lui
dit on y compris dans votre camp la
préférence nationale d'autres prises de
position écoutez je ne vois pas pourquoi
je ne m'étendrai davantage sur ce sujet
je pense vous avoir répondu de manière
claire et précise par référence à ce que
j'ai pu dire dans passé en ce qui me
concerne il n'y a aucune évolution alors
sur l'ump qui est parvenu à récolter les
11 millions nécessaires au règlement de
la dette de nicolas sarkozy après la
campagne présidentielle est ce que c'est
le signe selon vous que c'est 11
millions ont été récoltés que les
militants ump attend le retour de
nicolas sarkozy en tout cas c'est un
geste d'amitié et de sympathie vis-à-vis
lui vis-à-vis de l'ump chiens les deux
parce que nos militants je pense que
pour une large majorité d'entre eux ils
font pas trop la différence
ils sont fiers de ce qui a été fait avec
nicolas sarkozy déplore qu'il ait été
battu
il pense qu'il a fait un très beau score
ils se sont bien battus pour ça chacun à
sa place et à mon avis ils leur feront
la prochaine fois vous rencontrez vous
rencontrer souvent à nicolas sarkozy
régulier et encore aujourd'hui dans son
bureau
est-ce que vous avez paraît justement de
ses 11 millions us qu'il est surpris et
heureux de ce dénouement
il a été en effet très heureux que sa
parole est porté à un tel point et c'est
quelque chose qui lui fait chaud au
coeur bien entendu et ce qu'ils en
tirent des conclusions pour l'avenir on
va je pense que nicolas sarkozy garde
toute son intelligence sa lucidité son
énergie
et qu'il est animé par le souci de
l'avenir bon ballon à venir mais de
l'avenir de notre pays
ils raisonnent vous savez ils raisonnent
d'abord en termes de france c'est à dire
ils raisonnent en fonction de ce qu'il
estime être donc les intérêts de la
france bon et à cet égard il définira en
temps voulu le moment où il estimera
qu'il est audible mais pour vous en
retour on n'a jamais fait aucun doute
pour moi personnellement cela ne fait
pas de doute mais il lui a bien alors
que vous étiez encore avec les périls le
rappelait il ya quelques quelques heures
mais pour moi ça ne fait pas de doute d
d d d
dès le lendemain du 10 mai cela ne
faisait pas de doute et je pense qu'il
faut que les conditions soient présentes
dans le débat politique en terme de
situation économique de notre pays en
terme d'opinion publique mais en terme
d'opinion publique que le moment soit
venu pour qu'ils soient audibles pour
que son message porte ce qui laisse ce
qui lui laisse tout le temps nécessaire
de la réflexion pour construire ce qu'il
dira à ce moment là est ce que c'est le
moment du coup est ce que c'est le
moment opportun pour l'ump de lancer
l'inventaire du quinquennat de nicolas
sarkozy il va y avoir une convention de
l'ump au mas docteur sur son mon avis ce
sera une opération assez assez assez
rapide d'ailleurs vous savez qui on va
interrogés à ce sujet les ministres qui
est au gouvernement donc on leur
demandera d'évaluer leur transaction
puisque siens alors c'est parmi ceux qui
ont ni ce thème sur le tapis il y en à
d'assez nombreux qu'ils étaient très
heureux d'être au gouvernement qui ont
fait des pieds et des mains pour y être
et pour y rester bon donc on va leur
demander comme reese et vu leur
production donc ils sont comptables tout
aussi bien que le président qu'ils ont
servi qu'est-ce que
nicolas sarkozy vous dit de la
perspective de la primaire à l'ump car
et les cas extrêmes programmée avant la
barre technique mans de cette primaire
ce point n'a pas employé volet
fondamental été évoquée moi mon feeling
personnel c'est que le jour où nicolas
sarkozy sera revenue dans le jeu est
bien la primaire va s'évanouir
mais le programme et je voulais dire oui
à les programmes des candidats se
préparent
genève dans la veulent et filles ont par
exemple été terminée oui bien sûr mais
il a déjà été déterminé il a déjà été
déterminé à beaucoup de choses qui ne se
sont pas fait mais mais mais mais mais
bon mais mais mais mais bon nous verrons
bien
vous me demandez mon sentiment je vous
ai donné mon sentiment je pense qu'elle
va s'évanouir se diluer
je pense pourquoi pas voilà c'est une
référence chirac est vous avez donnez
combien vous personnellement au
sarkothon de g et comme les
parlementaires ont donné j'ai pas à vous
à vous à vous livrer un certain temps je
sais pas vous livrer mon temps de jeu je
suis pas favorable à ce déballage
permanent non est ce que vous estimez
que l'ump est en ordre de marche pour
les élections municipales de mars
prochain
alors les élections municipales c'est un
exercice particulier il faut adhérer au
terrain donc c'est pas le centre qui
crée les conditions du succès c'est les
équipes sur le terrain
vous savez tant de morts
quand on voit qu'on fait élire un député
dans la circonscription de villeneuve
sur lot où les conditions sont quand
même pas extraordinaire quand notre
tendance politique particulière oui
enfin je veux dire que le siège de vigne
sur historiquement il a été assez
rarement il a été dupe a longtemps
détenu par la droite donc un gros parfum
de scandale un oui vous à professeurs
oui mais quand on est là quand on a des
gens qui travaillent comme c'est le cas
de mon collègue maintenant député maire
de fumel et bien on ramasse
le profit de ce travail ingrat pendant
des années et des années
donc vous êtes confiant pour les
municipales ce qui pourrait servir les
élections certains les municipales
cependant chaque commune c'est pas
automatique c'est une question de
crédibilité
il faut unir il faut rassembler sur un
programme pour une commune donc c'est un
exercice qui est politique mais qui
n'est pas que politique c'est un
exercice de crédibilité alors en effet
les élections sénatoriales dépendent
pour une large part du nombre de
délégués qu'on peut aligner ensuite à
l'élection sénatoriale ya un débat
gérard larcher jean-pierre bel en ce
moment au retour de la classe du sénat
aux institutions gérard larcher parle du
déclin du sénat troupe qui seraient trop
peu considérée par l'actuel pouvoir
est ce que à votre avis également le
sénat ne sert plus à rien non le sénat
est aujourd'hui surtout champ économique
social et financier une chambre
d'opposition c'est une chambre qui ne
votent plus les textes du gouvernement
il n'y pourtant à gauche l'alizé
majorité qu elle est à gauche mais le
gouvernement ne peut plus faire voter ce
texte et par exemple lorsqu'il est
question d'un débat d'orientation
budgétaire le gouvernement s'abstient de
demander un vote puisqu'il le perdrait
donc le sénat joue son rôle il polarise
il exprime les mécontentements de la
société française tente à droite que je
suivrai à l'extrême gauche est ce que
cette absence de majorité à gauche
peut-être dû au fait
au président du sénat jean-pierre bel
qui ne tiendrait pas assez la maison
c'est ce qu'a dit le président du sénat
il n'est pas là pour tenir la maison
président du sénat le président d'une
assemblée il incarne cette assemblée
dans toute sa diversité
il est comme on dit un primus inter
pares s il est entre ses pairs entre ces
égos
c'est le rôle du président du sénat moi
je n'ai pas à me plaindre de jean pierre
bel qui est d'une grande courtoisie et
qui est qui et nausées moi qui sèment le
désordre
m non mais je pense que la présidence et
gérard larcher a raison de dire que le
sénat est amoindrie par tout ce qui est
fait à l'encontre de la ruralité et
risquent d'être amoindri par le non
cumul des mandats par le changement de
sa loi électorale ça nous complique
beaucoup de choses justement vous parler
du cumul des mandats
l'express a publié aujourd'hui le
palmarès des cumulards la république
alors vous arrivez en 15e position
german 6573 fc sion d'après les quelques
cours évoluent presque 10 de cumul
équivaut à 4 plein temps dont je voulais
vous remercier aujourd'hui d'avoir le
temps quelles fonctions vous avez mordu
pour venir sur public sénat ce soir non
mais je considère que sur un territoire
il faut qu'il y ait une unité de
responsabilité mais ceci ne peut se
faire qu'en équipe
je délègue beaucoup j'ai été adjoint des
vice-présidents qui travaillent en union
étroite avec moi il ya un partage des
rôles non je consacre beaucoup de temps
à mon territoire n'est pas vraiment huit
mandats ou fonctions en fait ça c'est
théorique alors si vous déléguez et je
suis maire du président de
l'agglomération dont je suis président
d'un gros syndicat mixte de déchets
ménagers je suis président de la maison
de l'emploi et de la formation du bureau
intercommunale
de l'emploi de la mission locale de de
toutes les structures que j'ai créé mon
titre en route vous les connaissez tous
bien non mais là je ne suis pas arrivé
au bout parce que je pense que 4ème
position c'est quand même très brillant
à partir d'une ville somme toute modeste
justement le projet de loi du
gouvernement permet va s'il est voté par
le parlement
limitera le cumul entre un mandat de
parlementaire et une fonction exécutive
mais pas entre une fille entre un mandat
de parlementaire une fonction non
exécutive du coup ça me va pas rayer
vraiment le problème du cumul en france
à mon avis cette loi est une très
mauvaise idée
elle va appauvrir la vocation politique
elle va appauvrir la représentation des
territoires
les contraires aux intérêts de notre
pays c'est une loi démagogique elle va
enrichir le personnel politique au sens
où il va se démultiplier d agréer des
rivalités elle va créer des zizanies
vous savez quand vous êtes maire d'une
ville centre et président de
l'intercommunalité vous avez davantage
de tensions a géré pendant qu'on gère
détention est ce qu on fait du travail
positif et ce qu'on travaille pour ses
concitoyens
on traite des affaires de boutique des
questions de personnes c'est pas très
intéressant franchement quel mandat est
ce que vous aimera abandonnez-vous si
j'ai bien compris bon d'abord je vais ex
participer à l'examen de ce texte que au
sénat je pense nous allons amendé
significativement donc si il est
suffisamment amendé par une majorité du
sénat je voterai le texte
ensuite l'assemblée nationale verra si
elle revient à sa version
si j'ai bien compris la date limite
c'est 2017 bon 2017 c'est pas encore
demain matin on verra d'ici là on verra
d'ici là merci épargné d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir malgré votre emploi du
temps donc si le déborder sa charge et
merci père michel la semaine prochaine
marine le pen sera l'invitée de proches
par trois on sera tous